did you allow the story to write itself
in some sense I realize this is about
anime and Stephen in the farm and all
that but did you go in with one idea of
how you wanted the film to be and then
it kind of told you another story we
worked with what we had you know and and
we knew we had all these incredible
births we knew they were so dramatic we
knew they are so beautiful so we didn't
know without said that we were going to
have that and that that would really be
sort of what the film the arc that the
film was sort of hung around were these
births that the universe stops along the
way or the journey and so that
definitely was something that sort of
you know revealed itself I think once we
had a general sense of what the
narrative was I remember we like sat
down and wrote like okay this is like
basically what the story could be and it
wasn't being like prettier blows to what
that was and I think that's partially
because its historical right you know so
I ography in some ways once you know the
gist of what it is you know once you've
heard the stories you kind of have a
sense of what it's going to be um but we
didn't we weren't able to include
everything historically because we
didn't necessarily have it covered very
well or when we tried to ask the
participants you know we didn't get it
didn't think their answers didn't flow
together you know I mean they're like a
million reasons why you can't
necessarily include something that you
may even want to if you can't get it
well if i dinnae i wouldn't talk about
it to you couldn't have you know some
sort of other character talking about
something that was very important it
just felt bizarre right but it was it
was you know it the historical part is
chronological and then so we knew that
you know we could rely on that and then
like I said before adding in the present
de verte stuff and then the births and
it was sort of like this how to weave
all that together but we knew we wanted
to make a portrait of ina may Gaskin
and the farm midwives and you know the
farm in some ways you know where they
lived in this community that they've
been a part of for 40 years so I think
we really set out to make a portrait and
then we came upon this archival footage
which was just like this treasure trip
we had no idea existed when we began so
and how did you know when to add what
you added just at certain points of when
someone would speak about something in
the past then you reflect it back to the
archival footage that you had and knew
that it was good I mean you did a
beautiful job waiting in and I was just
wondering what was your decision well I
think well Kate's such keh demand is
such a great editor and she has such a
she's done a lot of historical work as
well so she has just like incredible
instinct for for that kind of particular
work um but also like I remember a one
of the early issues that came up in the
Edit room was the film was like you are
already 45 minutes in before you saw at
birth you're like oh we need a bright
like end of Act one you got to have a
birth you know and so we we shifted a
berth and stuck it in where
chronologically it wouldn't have quite
happened yet in the at the farm you know
and that's not a first for that Pamela
has but but it sort of made sense in the
in the way that the film was traveling
and then even and then like you know
some time went by in the Edit room and
then we were like we view another birth
we always like at the beginning right
away yeah like right away and and I
remember or Johanna also said that
remember yeah it's like Tina quanti yeah
and then we're like okay and we just
threw it in there and it it never left
so it's like the film opens and there's
a birth like five seconds in if you've
never seen a birth before it got that
mystery or that like sense that you're
gonna do up to like wait because what's
gonna happen and I'm a little scared
like that's taken right off the table
right away those like it's done get used
to it because there's a lot more comfy
you know but it's funny how that like
you know was a process of like trying to
get this you know put them in in the
right spots right i think it was at your
QA or before the LA film festival
premiere i think one of you said have
you ever seen a worthy for a while you
know now i gotta get over it if you're
scared or something
you